arno fabre bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors du côté des syndicats
d'enseignants plusieurs procédures de
demande d'expertisé ont été activés à la
suite de ces révélations et votre
collectif les stylos rouges a pour sa
part annoncé son intention de déposer
plainte
bien entendu suite aux déclarations du
président de la république qui hier nous
sommes confortés dans cette volonté
et bien tout simplement que les
ministres que le gouvernement puisse
rendre des comptes
je crois que depuis longtemps monsieur
macron le premier à oublier que la
france est bien n'est pas une monarchie
mais bien une démocratie où le peuple a
son mot à dire et à partir de là et bien
on voit toutes les incohérences tout
l'improvisation des décisions qui sont
prises et il n'y a pas besoin d'être un
grand expert pour s'en rendre compte
donc à partir de là pour ce qui est de
l'école ce qui est très important c'est
qu'on me voilà les masses qui finalement
c'est masqué toxic ne sont finalement
qu'une énième goutte d'eau dans
l'irresponsabilité des décisions qui
sont prises les stylos rouges comme
d'autres collectifs comme certains
syndicats avaient demandé très
clairement la reprise des cours est bien
en demi groupe
tout simplement pour éviter et bien la
propagation du virus et bien et ça nous
a été tous ont refusé et s'est même hors
de question selon le ministre alors que
des choses extrêmement simple pour être
mis en place notamment quand les enfants
n'étaient pas pris en charge à l'école
en denis par ap en demi journée certains
donné le matin d'août stagné
l'après-midi les mairies aurait pu ne
s'en occupait il ya des locaux communaux
même dans les petites communes il y à
des agents communaux donc certes il sort
agnès aurait nécessité une part
d'improvisation et peut-être aussi de
réflexion pour tout simplement permettre
et bien à la fois que l'école ait lieu
quais les parents puissent continuer à
les travailler mais surtout que
l'épidémie est bien au moins soit
contenue car là on
voit les principaux kloster de france
sont et bien les écoles les collèges les
lycées et les universités contrairement
à risque diminue ce qui s'étonnent des
chiffres de santé publique france c'est
quand même le comble est ce que vous
avez connaissance d'une note qui assure
que les notes du ministère vous
demandant justement de ne plus porter
ses basques
jusqu'à présent n'ont pas du tout non
non officiellement ceux qui n'ont pas
écouté la télé concrètement et bien vous
écouter la radio ne vois là on doit
continuer à porter ces masses puisque
c'est ce qu'ils nous ont été distribués
dans les faits plus personne ne les
portent bien évidemment mais on voit
bien là le décalage c'est à dire que le
ministre le pass de plateau en plateau
on le voit là encore effectivement il
fait de belles conférence de presse mais
à aucun moment et bien il ne nous
protège et ce tous il me protège donc le
les professeurs on rappelle qu'il ya que
tu ne m'aimes plus de 200 mille
professeurs qu'en france qui ont plus de
55 ans sans parler bien de tous les
personnels administratifs qui sont des
personnes vulnérables qui pour certains
ou des pathologies humaines en étant
plus jeune et ces gens là sont obligés
de se rendre au travail et tous les
jours alors le problème n'est pas qu'ils
aillent au travail mais on pourrait par
exemple mettre en place du télétravail
pour ces personnes c'est ce qu'il se
mettait en place ce qui avait été fait
en mai ou en jean la deuxième chose
c'est que cela souligne l'absence d'
écoute complète et de considération pour
recoller les pots le concours des
professeurs il suffit de voir les
promesses d'augmentation de salaire
écoutez on est et parmi les salaires les
plus bas de l'oscd eu d'accord il a même
pas de prime de risque
si au moins ailleurs nous avait dit bon
écoute et vous continuez à les
travailler dans ces conditions
comme les gens dès qu'ils travaillent
dans le métro qui doivent prendre le
métro pour ceux qui vont au travail
voilà il ya une prime de risque n'a rien
du tout rien du tout c'est à dire que la
concrètement on a bien affaire à
quelqu'un qui en plus
mentir devant la représentation
nationale monsieur blanc caire et en
expliquant qu'il n'y a pas de problème
dans les écoles de la même manière que
la ministre des transports expliqué
qu'il n'y avait pas de problème à
prendre le métro
bon on se rend bien compte que les
déclarations des ministres sous d'un
décalage complet avec la réalité est
qu'en plus de ça et bien la solution qui
trouvait la sortie du chapeau et bien de
ce couvre-feu
c'est en fait une réduction de nos
libertés qui malheureusement est sans
rapport avec le danger de l'épidémie
c'est ça ce couvre feu c'est un leurre
et c'est un leurre parce que par exemple
monsieur blanc coeur est au pouvoir
depuis trois ans et demi et d'un court
il découvre et bien que oui on va
peut-être lâché un peu d'argent une
prime de 150 euros bruts annuels
d'équipement avec 15 euros par mois ça
c'est sûr qu'on va pouvoir acheter un
ordinateur ou ouvriers c'est consternant
arno fabre merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
administrateur national du mouvement des
stylos rouges martial merci